hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation and today
I'm going to take a result that some
physicists some commentators have
described as the most profound result in
theoretical and experimental physics I'm
not sure I would agree with it as the
most profound but without a doubt it
ranks among the top few of the most
remarkable most surprising insights that
have emerged a in the last hundred
hundred and fifty years so it's well
worth spending a little time thinking
about it and the topic that we're
focusing upon is the possibility that
our world allows for influences that are
non-local what does that mean a
non-local impose what's a local
influence well that's an ordinary
influence and you do something whatever
you know you snap your fingers you clap
your hands you push something you move
something around and the influence that
you exert manifests in your local
environment it's unusual to imagine that
you could say punch your fist forward
and like hit somebody in the back of the
head or in the nose on the other side of
the country
I don't sort of like violent metaphor
but but you sort of get the gist what
you do according to logical reasoning
what you do according to everyday
experience what you do according to the
laws of physics as we thought we
understood them prior to what I'm going
to talk about here today what you do
here influences things here it doesn't
influence things instantaneously or
immediately someplace far away from here
so locality is you exert an influence it
affects your local environment non
localities the possibility that you
exert some kind of influence and it
affects something far away and it was
the insight of a variety of individuals
we'll talk about a number of them
today but you know and bring them up on
the screen Albert Einstein right here
played a essential role in the story
that I'm going to describe here because
it was his insight together with two
colleagues I'll show you them in a
moment Podolsky and Rosen that came up
with an idea that ultimately rippled
through our understanding of physics
giving us a radically different picture
than even Albert Einstein would have
anticipated and this relies upon a
variety of ideas having to do with
quantum mechanics quantum entanglement
the culminating effort in this direction
emerges with this guy over here who
among physicists is is extraordinarily
well known for the general public less
well known this is John Bell and Irish
physicist who as we will see was able to
take a completely abstract theoretical
idea almost a a metaphysical idea at
least it seemed metaphysical in the
sense that it didn't seem to have any
experimental consequences that Einstein
and his colleagues came up with and Bell
was able to show that Einsteins idea was
not metaphysics that Einsteins idea was
physics which meant
I'm Stein's idea could be tested indeed
as we'll see he wrote down the test and
later on physicists came along and
carried out that test to profound effect
okay so here are the three main culprits
in the story
Einstein Boris Podolsky and Nathan Rosen
and it was in 1935 that they wrote this
paper over here and you may if you've
been following the series you'll note
that in the episode on quantum
entanglement now I don't know what
episode it was you don't have to have
watched that episode to understand the
discussion here today but it would help
if you looked at that so in that episode
I described the basic idea of
tangle mint and the basic conclusion of
the paper that Einstein and his
colleagues wrote here but I'll remind
you of that again and again the the
overarching implication or the
overarching message of Einsteins paper
with these two colleagues was not that
quantum mechanics was wrong so this
headline in the New York Times really
spot-on scientist and two colleagues
finding that quantum mechanics is not
complete even though it is correct so
Einstein and Podolsky and Rosen we're
never saying that quantum mechanics is
wrong in the sense that it makes
predictions that are in conflict with
observation or experiment what they were
saying instead was the the view of
reality that quantum mechanics puts
forward is an incomplete description of
reality and Einstein and his colleagues
were arguing that there has to be a
deeper description even though they were
unable to give that deeper description
they believe that in this paper they had
established that there was a deeper
description waiting to be found and and
their analysis relied on this idea of
quantum entanglement which pictorially
is this idea that you can have two
particles that can be widely separated
and yet there's still a kind of quantum
mechanical thread an invisible thread I
showed here in yellow just to sort of
give it a little visualization but it's
as if there's an invisible quantum
mechanical connection that links these
two particles regardless of how far our
part they are and allows it to be the
case according to standard quantum
mechanics that if you do something to
one of these particles say the one on
the right it can have an immediate
influence on a measurement on the
particle on the left of the image even
though they might be miles kilometers
light-years apart that is very strange
and this is why Einstein called this
spooky right it was a spooky implication
of bread-and-butter quantum mechanics
that you could set up two particles in
this manner such that you perform a
measurement on one of those particles
and it immediately instantaneously has
an impact on a measurement undertaken on
the partner particle regardless of how
far apart I mean that's crazy sanity
talk right but yeah that's what standard
quantum mechanics seemed to be implying
and Einstein and his colleagues came
along and said we don't buy that we
believe there's a different picture and
I'll show you what the picture is a time
some Podolsky and Rosen put forward and
that picture is ultimately with John
Bell analyzed and showed that that new
picture could actually be subject to
experimental tests and as you'll see the
way in which Einstein and his colleagues
envisioned the world behaving is not
actually borne out by the experiments
it's not fully refuted as some say and
I'm gonna come to that subtlety toward
the very end but the image that Einstein
had of a world in which influences would
be local seems not to be our reality it
seems to be the case and I'm hedging my
description only because at the end I'll
describe one or two potential loopholes
in this conclusion but the most
straightforward reading of the
discussion that I'm going to have here
now is that our quantum mechanical world
does allow this kind of nonlocality it
does allow a measurement in one location
to have an influence on a measurement
taking place at a distant location
regardless of how far apart they are all
right so I'm not going to follow the
precise way in which Einstein and his
colleagues came to this conclusion
instead I'm going to use the same kind
of example that I used in the discussion
earlier of quantum entanglement that
earlier episode which makes use of this
property of particles called spin
quantum mechanical spin now not
everybody's familiar with quantum
mechanical spin
roughly speaking for the purposes that
we have at hand here you can think about
it as follows
particles have a quality that allows you
to think about them as if they're
spinning around like a top and any given
species of particle has a fixed amount
of this quantum mechanical spin the
Higgs boson
was so special because it has none of
this quantum mechanical spin it's the
first particle that we've ever
encountered that doesn't have a certain
amount of spin has it well it does have
a certain amount it's zero in that
particular case but electrons and quarks
and the familiar matter particles have
an amount of quantum mechanical spin
called spin 1/2 all that means
pictorially which is fine for what we're
discussing here is this so you can have
a particle and I kind of hope you can
see this as particle is actually
spinning around get close to your screen
if you don't see it yeah I think you can
probably see it so it's spinning around
in this particular case it's going in a
clockwise orientation the particle can
also spin around this axis the other
direction the same amount roughly
speaking the same speed of spin if you
will and we have an arrow that we could
point directly in the direction of the
spin as in this particular case here
with the orange arrow or the other
direction we could have this purple our
going say in this counterclockwise
direction it's really awkward to try to
have ours that spin around with the
particle so we use different notation so
for this case instead of having the
arrow going around with a particle we
say that the particle is spinning up
which is just the right-hand rule take
your fingers you curl it in the
direction of the spin and your thumb
points in the direction that we use to
describe that kind of spinning motion so
in this case counterclockwise spinning
up and the opposite would be spinning
down and again you have to get really
close to see it but that particle is
spinning around in this clockwise
direction which by this right hand rule
would be spinning down now the weirdness
of quantum mechanics really comes to the
fore when we realize
that quantum mechanics allows a particle
to be in kind of a fuzzy mixture of both
spinning up and spinning down at the
same time and it's hard to to show that
pictorially but take a look at this
right so this is this is not a really
good depiction but it gives you a rough
sense that it's kind of up and down the
problem of this imagery is at any given
moment if I was to stop this animation
the hour would be up or it would be down
which would mean at a given moment it
had one or the other spin that's not
what quantum mechanics tells us quantum
mechanics tells us that the particle is
in a mixture of both spins at the same
time so I can't really depict that but
this is you know not a bad visual image
visual metaphor to have in mind and only
when you measure the particle does it
snap to attention and acquire a single
definite spin in this case it snapped to
attention spinning in the upward
direction but if this is a 50-50 mixture
half probability of up 1/2 probability
of down then you know if I measure it
again it could be up or down 50/50
chance and in this particular animation
it turned out that that second
measurement gives this particle spinning
in the downward direction so it's weird
very strange quantum mechanics allowing
this sort of fuzzy nebulous reality
until a measurement or an interaction
takes place which forces that reality to
ante up and choose one or the other
outcome in this particular case only two
possible outcomes the particle chooses
one or the other only when the particle
is confronted by a measurement or
confronted by an appropriate interaction
that disambiguates this blending of
possibilities which is the reality prior
to that interaction so totally strange
but this is the standard part of quantum
mechanics it's kind of weirdness and its
own right but now we go further and the
weirdness of quantum entanglement as
applied to this particular exam
full of quantum mechanically spinning
particles is this according to quantum
mechanics you can set up a situation we
have two particles each of which is in
this fuzzy mixture of spinning up and
down at the same time but you can set it
up so that their spins are correlated so
that they're both in a 50/50 mixture up
and down but the spin of one is opposite
to the spin of the other in the sense
that if you were to set up this
situation they're both sort of 50 up 50
down let's say you go to the particle on
the right you measure it it snaps out of
the haze purple pointing up and the
particle on the left or at least my left
is pointing down I always get confused
if your left and my left it'll be the
same so I hope that what I'm going right
and left is not reverse but be that as
it may the purple one is spinning up and
the orange one is spinning down and and
the curious feature of this is I only
interacted with the purple particle or
the one that turned out to be purple and
it forced the other particle to
disambiguate and spin down once the one
that turned out to be spinning up
acquired that definite spin that's the
weirdness of quantum entanglement
because these two particles could be
arbitrarily far apart and an image that
makes us a little bit more dramatic in
its schematic but it's more energetic if
you will here are two entangled
particles and this 50/50 mixture
spinning up and spinning down I go to
the particle on the right and to measure
it it spins down immediately the one on
the Left snaps out of the haze and spins
up again I can do this again there 50/50
mixture up and down let's say go to the
park on the left and I measure it and it
snaps out of the haze spinning down the
one on the right will snap out of the
haze instantaneously spinning the
opposite orientation and that is the
weirdness of quantum entanglement and
that's the spooky mists of it right I
mean how could it be that you measure
one and it affects the other so what
does Einstein do well let me show you
what he does
in the context of taking these abstract
examples of spinning particles let me
put them into more of a laboratory
setting okay so in a laboratory setting
we can imagine that we have say a couple
of detectors and one detector on the
right one detector on the left and in
the middle is a is a device if you will
that will send out particles that are
entangled so this device in the middle
creates entangled particles and it
creates them in just the way that we've
been describing one up one down the
other up the other down and so forth and
these detectors are able to measure the
spins of the particles so the example
that it was just showing a second ago in
this language would look like this
two particles say are emitted from the
center device they're both in the
mixture up and down and then they get
measured on the left and the right and
when they're measured one is up ones
down or in the reverse case the others
down the other is up and so forth but
the weirdness the spookiness is that
they're in a fuzzy mixture and yet upon
measurement they both disambiguate that
both choose a definite reality even
though they're far apart they're able to
correlate the outcomes that's that's the
weirdness so far apart and yet they
never get it wrong when one's up the
others down when one's down the other is
up amazing right so what does Einstein
said of this he says look he says that's
too damn spooky for me he says I think
what's really going on here is not that
these particles are in this fuzzy
mixture of up and down until they get to
the detectors and only upon measurement
do they snap out to be one way or the
other he says that would require some
spooky crosstalk between them some some
spooky conversation between these widely
separated particles he says the world
doesn't work that way so he says
I have got a much simpler explanation
for what's really going on here
he says if a detector measures a
particle and finds it spinning up then
it always was spinning up it was never
in this fuzzy mixture spinning up and
down as a math of quantum mechanics
tells us he says the math of quantum
mechanics is simply unable to get at the
full and complete description of reality
and that's why it seems to us by staring
at the equations that a particle is in a
fuzzy mixture of up and down until
measurement when in reality it always
was up or down from the get-go and then
to explain how and this one's down this
one's up very simply this was always
down and this was always up and that's
how they were from the get-go and these
detectors simply revealed the definite
spin that they already had so
pictorially be like this we have here
the spins of the particles coming out
and their definite from the get-go
according to Einstein Podolsky and Rosen
the one on the right at least my right
is spinning up the one on the left is
spinning down and that's all there is to
it so of course as they race toward
their two detectors they maintain those
spins and the detectives reveal those
spins so Einstein says here is what's
really going on particles have definite
properties even though quantum mechanics
can't give up those definite properties
quantum mechanics only gives us
probabilities of those definite
properties but definite properties of
particles have and they're opposite to
each other on the left and the right and
therefore it's no surprise that the
measurements always yield this perfect
anti-correlation one is up the others
down ones down and the other is up
nothing spooky at all in this in stein
Ian Podolsky and Rosen description of
the true underlying reality
so this is what the New York Times meant
when they said that Einstein Podolsky
and Rosen were not saying that quantum
mechanics is wrong they're saying it's
incomplete they're saying that sure the
predictions of quantum mechanics spot-on
accurate but the true picture of reality
that underlies the mathematical
description is quite different they are
claiming from the reality that's
manifest in the quantum mechanical
mathematics according to quantum
mechanics particles can be in this
mixture and then measured they snap out
of the haze Einstein says no no no no
they always had a definite spin it's
just that you're in complete quantum
mathematics it's unable to tell us that
definite disposition and because your
theory is incomplete it's reduced to
giving probabilistic descriptions of a
reality but that's only a description
that's not how reality actually works
now when Einstein came forward with this
idea there is definitely some how should
I say it well there is concern you know
that Einstein maybe was pointing out a
failing of quantum mechanics maybe
Einstein was right but then people began
to think about it more fully and they
began to realize or at least that began
to think that they realized that
Einsteins view of reality could never be
test it fundamentally couldn't be tested
right I mean this guy over here Wolfgang
Pauli he said that
einstein-podolsky-rosen view of reality
was no better than the ancient question
of how many angels can dance on the head
of a pin it was something that was on
Tesla now why would it be untestable
well you see Einstein is saying that
before you measure the particle it has a
definite spin or as quantum mechanics
says it's in a mixture right but how do
you verify that picture without
measuring the particle the only way you
can learn the disposition of the part
by measuring it but after measurement
Einstein agrees that it will have a
definite value say up or down and
quantum mechanics agrees that it will
have a definite value up or down they
only differ these two views of reality
only differ from each other prior to the
measurement how can you ever test
something that's prior to the
measurement it's as if I said to you hey
guys
did you know that I actually have pink
hair but anytime you look at me my hair
turns white or gray or whatever whatever
color my hair is right my statement that
I have pink hair when you're not looking
is fundamentally untestable because the
tests that you need to look but I'm
stipulating that when you look my hair
is no longer pink so poly makes the
analogy to angels dancing on the head of
a pin and and you're niels bohr who was
Einstein's you know deep partner in
trying to understand the the fundamental
laws of physics you know Bohr's view was
he said look it is a mistake to think
that we physicists are in the business
of trying to find the true nature of
reality
nonsense Bohr says we are in the
business of trying to find the equation
that will make accurate predictions for
the results of measurements and if you
try to think that we physicists are
doing anything more than that you're
going to run into problems and that he
says is what Einstein has run into he
basically says in the end if there's no
experimental difference between the
Einsteinian view of the underlying rail
in the quantum mechanical view of the
underlying reality then then we're not
talking physics any longer so Einstein
Einstein passes away in 1955 Bohr passes
away in 1962 and this issue of what the
true nature of the world
is the world and the fuzzy probabilistic
haze until measured or until there's a
suitable interaction or is the world
actually definite in your measurements
just reveal that definite reality which
of those pictures is correct people
basically don't pay a lot of attention
to the issue for a period of time
because they think it's fundamentally
untestable fundamentally not physics
fundamentally perhaps philosophy I don't
mean that in the derogatory way meaning
more of a philosophical view of how the
world is opposed to a physicists view of
the things that we can measure in the
world and that's where this guy I
mentioned early on in this episode John
Stuart Bell comes into the story because
in 1964 he writes a paper I'll show you
that paper in just a moment he writes a
paper that shows the Einstein view of
reality is testable Pauli was wrong it's
not about angels dancing on the head of
a pin Bell surprisingly shows that
Einsteins view of a world in which
qualities are always definite that
yields a measurable difference in
experimentally distinct prediction from
the quantum mechanical prediction how
does he how does he do this well I'm
gonna focus on the little example that
we've been looking about particle spin I
mean the the paper that Bell writes is
much more general than that but let's
just try to get at the heart of the
manner what is the essential new idea
that Bell introduces he says look let me
just imagine doing that laboratory
experiment with the spinning particles
with the two detectors and opposite ends
of the laboratory bench but let me
imagine that I went to you know the
physics supply store and I got some
better detectors upgraded detectors
imagine that the detectors don't just
measure the spin along one axis the
vertical axis that we were looking at
imagine that it can measure the particle
spin about three different axes axis one
X is two and axis three now exactly what
those axes are does matter to the
mathematical version of the argument
that I'm about to give you you don't
really need to know that because I'm
going to focus sort of at a higher level
we will do the mathematical analysis but
we won't get into that level of detail
but just in case you're interested the
three axes that that bill envisions are
axes that are at a hundred and twenty
degrees relative to one in others so you
know this axis that acting like a peace
sign that axis this axis and this axis
and and so what this detector does is
when the particle comes in you the user
the experimenter pick one of the three
axes while the particle is say in flight
you pick axis one or two or three and
the outcome will be the measurement of
the particle spin along that axis now
the the weirdness of bread-and-butter
quantum mechanics that nobody is
questioning is that the result of that
measurement will always be spin up or
spin down
along that axis now I'm not going to
distinguish in the readout the different
orientations always show up or down but
you take it to mean that it's up or down
along axis one if I pick one up and down
along axis two if I pick setting two on
the detector similarly up or down along
axis three if I choose setting number
three and again just so it's clear
here's here's Bell's paper which you
know I can just thumb through it again
it's not long and you see that you know
there's more general mathematical
analysis that you see in this but it's
nothing more than basic quantum
mechanics linear algebra on this
right-hand page toward the bottom a
little bit of calculus but that's it
right that that's the end of this paper
which gives us in the end as we will see
a shocking insight shocking conclusion
but the version of understanding this at
a pedagogical level that I will follow
following this example of the particle
spins I
learn from this guy over here David
Merman I was a professor at Cornell in
the 1990s David Merman has been a
Cornell for a very long time I think he
may be retired now and he just has this
spectacular knack for drilling down and
and really finding the heart of an
argument and I remember I went to a
colloquium at Cornell where David Merman
was explaining Belle's ideas and and I
sort of heard of Belle's ideas that that
don't look I was a faculty member at
that time I sort of knew about those
ideas but I didn't really know about
Belle's ideas and after this colloquium
of David mermans I was just like walking
around and kind of state of shock when I
finally understood in an intuitive way
that I will explain right now what John
Bell was telling us okay so let me show
you then how the argument goes in this
particular version that David Merman
gives us so here's our detector we can
choose axes one access to access three
and each of these detectors are in this
configuration and now I should say when
a particle pair is emitted by this
particle creation in the center there it
sends the particles out left and right
now the particles have to have definite
spins along all three of the possible
axes according to Albert Einstein
Einstein says again particles have
definite features when you measure
something you measure something that's
already there so for measuring the
particle spins along axis one then the
particle better have a definite value of
the spin along axis one and you see it
right here the left particle it's
spinning up along axis one and the right
again they're completely anti-correlated
that's the nature of this entangled
State but you see particle 1 particle on
the left along the first axis is
spinning up particle number 2 along the
first axis is spinning down similarly
the particle on my left along the second
axis you got the purple pointing down
the corresponding
measurement on its partner entangled
partner particle on the right the middle
arrow is spinning up and finally you see
that the third arrow on the Left
particle spinning up the third hour on
the right is spinning down so according
to Einstein and colleagues this is the
true nature of the underlying reality
it's none of this business along these
axes and now the explanation for the
results in this view of reality would be
completely clear so let's imagine we've
run some experiments let's say we pick
axis one for the detector on the left
and the right that means the first arrow
for each of the entangled particles
dictates the outcome and you see the one
on the Left is spinning up and the one
on the right is spinning down now if I
pick the second axis for both of these
it's the second arrow and the triples
that matter so you got spinning down and
left spinning up on the right and for
good measure
let's set the detector to be access
three and it's a third arrows of each of
these triplets that matters spinning up
on the Left spinning down on the right
and the detector simply reveal the
underlying quality of the particle that
einstein and his colleagues say is truly
the nature of the deep description of
reality now so far you say okay so john
bell doesn't seem to have done very much
we're just doing the same kind of
experiment but now we're just have the
choice of picking the axes but here's
the thing
in the three examples that I just gave
you I happen to choose the axes on the
Left detector and the right detector to
be the same left was one right was one
left those two right was two left of
three right was three but we don't have
to choose this is the freedom of this
new scenario we don't have to choose the
axes to be the same I could choose
different axes for each of the two
detectors like I could choose on the
left
maybe I choose setting number two and on
the right I choose one or on the left I
choose three or on the right I choose
two and so forth right
and with this newfound freedom to have
different settings on the two detectors
we can now get results quite different
from what we've gotten so far so far all
of our results worth this one's up this
one's down this one's down this one's up
but now in this case we can get
situations where both are up and both
are down and that's important as we will
see so let me take a look at that so
let's do an example here's a case where
you got three on the left two on the
right in terms of the detector settings
and what's the result going to be well
look the three on the left means it's
the third arrow and the triplet on the
left is pointing up the two on the right
means it's the middle arrow for the
particle on the right it's also pointing
up and therefore your result will be
up-and-up hmm a new result the kind of
result that we didn't see before let me
do another example let's say I choose my
detector settings to be two on the left
and one on the right that means it's the
middle arrow on the left that's relevant
because it's a second axis it's the
first arrow on the right that's relevant
because I chose that detector to measure
along the first of the three possible
axes so that means I'm going to get two
on the Left which is spinning down and
one on the right that's also spinning
down so I should get down down and what
do we get down down the detectors work
they do exactly what they are meant to
do and so what this means is if I then
run many many versions of this
experiment particle pair after particle
pair going toward the detectors as
they're in flight saying I have you know
a team of physicists at the left
detector team of physicists at the right
detector and they say randomly picking
the axes what will happen if they'll get
a whole slew of different answers
you know sometimes it'll be up and down
sometimes it'll be down and up you know
sometimes it will be up and down
sometimes they'll both be the same you
know in that case it was down down so
you could then imagine I'm doing this
experiment over and over and over
again and just collecting a whole lot of
data for the outcomes and here's where
Belle's insight comes to the fore Bell
argues and I'll show you the argument in
this case right now
Bell argues that if you to do this
experiment many many many times randomly
choosing the detector settings on each
run of the experiment he argues that the
results in which they are anti Carly up
and down at least five ninths of the
time the particles have to have that
disposition as opposed to this or this a
prediction that emerges from this view
of reality that particles have definite
spins along all of these axes that are
being measured let me show you how that
argument goes it's quite simple so if
you think about it there are obviously
nine combinations of possible detector
settings one on the left one on the
right one on the left two on the right
one and three two and one you've got
three possibilities for the left
detector three for the right detector
three times three is nine so there are
nine possible joint settings of these
two detectors and what I want to do
following David mermans version of John
Bell I want to analyze the results that
we will get for one particular value of
the spin of the two entangled particles
so let's just look at an example of that
here so imagine that my particle is up
down up on the Left down up down on the
right now I'm just gonna go detector
setting by detector setting to see what
I would get so if the detector settings
are 1 & 1 first axis in both of the
detectors and it's the first arrow in
each of the triples that matter so I get
up and down what if the detector setting
was say one on the left and two on the
right then it's the first error on the
left and it's a second error on the
right that's an up up and now you see I
can just continue to fill in the table
I've got the data in front of me
so if it was 2 & 2 would be the second
arrow that'd be down and up to
and three it'd be down and down because
I now have the down arrow from the
particle on the right and so forth
alright so I continue to fill in the
table now let me look at the number of
outcomes in which the spins are opposite
to each other I'm just going to
highlight those so we have them up on
the screen and there you have them those
are the only ones in which they are
opposite and we got one two three four
five five out of nine of the outcomes
have the spins pointing in opposite
directions
okay that was just one example though
let me do another example for you this
was an example where particle on the
Left was up down up particle on the
right the entangled pair partner was
down up down let's look at another
possibility let's just for instance look
at a particle on the left hand side
where it's up up down and therefore down
down up now as you can see it's the same
basic analysis they'll just the results
would be shifted around a little bit so
I fill in the table just so you can sort
of see it again let me focus on those
that have opposite spins which results
have opposite ends and again one two
three four five out of the nine possible
outcomes have the spins being opposite
now you might say well yeah you're only
looking at very special cases but if you
have two particles and three axes then
at least two of the spin directions have
got to be the same there are only two
possible spins up or down you got three
possible axes so you're gonna have two
of them the same at least the only
situation that's fundamentally different
from the example that I've been looking
at here is a case when all of the spins
are the same so let's look at that case
so imagine on the Left particle you have
up up up on the right particle you've
got down down down now every outcome
along every measurement combination of
the axes will give opposite answer so in
this case you'll have nine out of nine
giving opposite spin results for these
nine possible measure
so it's five out of nine when all the
spins along all three axes are not the
same it's nine out of nine when they are
the same therefore if you imagine
running this experiment over and over
and over again where you're just looking
at random entangled particles with
random detector settings over a huge
number of runs of this experiment at
least five ninths of these results will
have opposite spins on the left and the
right at least that because some of them
will have it nine nines at the time so
an average it's at least 55% of the time
you will get opposite spin results that
is a prediction of the Einsteinian view
of the world that particles have
definite spins prior to them being
measured and here's the thing you can
now test this result you can do the
experiment there's nothing really
gaddafi enlike these aren't thought
experiments I mean when Bell first wrote
the sound he knew that in principle you
could undertake these measurements they
really weren't undertaken fully until
the late 70s early 80s they've been
refined ever since and here is what
happens when you actually do this
experiment you do not get opposite spins
five ninths of the time you get opposite
pins less than five ninths of the time
in fact they get opposite spins 50% of
the time not 55% of the time and
therefore Einstein's view of the world
is in conflict not with our intuition
not with our desire for how the world
should be it's in conflict with actual
experiments that are delineating how the
world is and I should point out the
result that you do get from the
experiments agrees with the calculation
that comes at a standard quantum
mechanics
standard quantum mechanics without this
idea that particles have definite
features that particles truly are in
this fuzzy mixture spinning up and
spinning down at the same time it agrees
with the experiment but Einstein
Podolsky and Rosen z-- version of
reality does not now what are we to make
of this
well you might immediately conclude that
Einsteins you that particles have
definite features is what's being ruled
out here and based on how I've described
things I don't blame you for thinking
that way but let me now take you back
through the chain of reasoning Einstein
said the world is not spooky you don't
have an influence here affecting
something else over there and in order
to get rid of spooky action he
envisioned that particles had definite
features so the whole point of the
einstein-podolsky-rosen view of reality
is to get rid of spooky action to get
rid of nonlocality by saying that the
particles don't have to correlate their
behaviors over long distances they
already have definite features and the
detectives are simply revealing those
features so Einstein is really assuming
that the world is local and that the
world has these qualities hidden
variables is often called these hidden
qualities these definite features even
if they may be beyond our ability to
know about those definite features until
they are measured so that view of
reality is being wiped out by these
measurements and so what we're really
learning is the world cannot be local
and have these hidden qualities now you
cannot it cannot be locally have these
inequalities telling us therefore is
that in principle could be non-local and
have these hidden qualities that's not
ruled out or it can simply be non-local
and not have hidden qualities which is
the approach that standard quantum
mechanics takes but the bottom line is
what's really being ruled out by
all analysis is that the world is local
we're learning that these particles
behaving like this and like this are
making use of a non-local
connection in the manner that standard
quantum mechanics shows should be there
so that is the import of this whole
analysis of einstein-podolsky-rosen john
bell it's to come to a conclusion that
this vision of the world that comes down
to us from isaac newton that the world
should be local we learn that that
picture runs afoul of the quantum
mechanical measurements measurements of
quantum mechanical systems establish
that picture is ruled out the world has
non-local qualities now I said that with
a certain degree of firmness and now I
just want to take a baby step backward
because it's very hard in physics to
have fully air-tight conclusions and
it's always a matter of what assumptions
you're making what paradigm within which
you're working and as I've mentioned a
few times in these episodes quantum
mechanics and many of us believe is not
yet a subject in which every T has been
crossed and every eye has been dotted
there is this issue of the quantum
measurement problem and measurement is
all part of this story what's the
quantum measurement problem we don't
know how even in standard quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics does not
tell us how the world transitions from a
fuzzy mixture of up and down or fuzzy
mixture of particle being at various
potential locations to the single
definite reality upon measurement we
don't know how that happens and without
knowing how that happens there are
potential loopholes to any conclusions
that we draw for instance there is an
approach to quantum mechanics called the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and it highlights an S
a third hidden assumption behind
everything that we are doing here take
the einsteinium view of the world
Einstein is saying the world is local
assumption number one the world
therefore has hidden properties in order
to explain long distance correlations
number three Einstein is also assuming
that when you undertake a measurement it
yields one unique answer we are assuming
that when these particles go to these
detectors the detectors are yielding one
answer up or down the many-worlds
approach challenges that the many-worlds
approach says mm hmm if the particles in
this mixture of up and down then when
it's measured you get up in one universe
and down in another universe you get
both answers if you look at the totality
of this larger reality that encompasses
all of the universes and therefore
that's another way out from the
conclusions of this john bell
theoretical result together with the
experimental measurements you could in
principle have a universe that's local
doesn't have these definite qualities
these hidden variables whose hidden
qualities and scoots around the
incompatibility with the experimental
measurements by saying measurements
don't have unique outcomes that is
another way to violate the conclusion
and in that way be compatible with the
experimental observations putting that
to the side so that's an interesting
possibility maybe I'll talk about many
worlds in in a subsequent discussion
allow me to put many worlds to the side
I mean that's that's that's so far out
in our view of reality that that so
radically changes our description of the
world that that I would not consider
that in some sense as restoring us to
more familiar few the world that that's
of thought that that's even more extreme
if you will then the nonlocality
interpretation so let me just put that
one to the side for a second
but so so put it to the side we are led
to the conclusion that the world is not
local that the world allows these
non-local influency do something here
and it can affect the outcome of a
measurement over there and this is now
coming not from from pure theorizing
this is coming from a blending of
theoretical insights that start with
Einstein Podolsky and Rosen people think
that there's no experimental consequence
to this view of the world that it's
local and particles have definite
qualities people think that it's
metaphysics john bell comes along and
shows that is not metaphysics and others
come along klaus your ass pay and others
they do these measurements and they show
that einstein's view of the world is not
compatible with the observations and
something's got to give and at least in
the traditional description putting many
worlds to the side the thing that has to
give is that the world is local alright
that is a stunning stunning conclusion
this has been a a longer episode than
usual but i hope that you found it
worthwhile because these ideas are there
just like spectacular these are the
ideas that make you really sit up and
recognize that there's so much more to
the world than you think
based on everyday observation and what
can be more exciting than that
alright so this bell result this bell
theorem is your equation for today that
is your daily equation I look forward to
seeing you at the next episode until
then take care